[Music]
what are you doing tonight at 7.
so two guys
one cup
take me to it not exactly all right
sorry
but
[Music]
is a euphemism it's by papua new guinea
oh they got headhunters there very cool
yeah a lot of dangerous [ __ ] over there
yeah
so um
they spent 29 days lost at sea after the
gps tractor uh tracker stopped working
oh
29 they what did they thought
they didn't [ __ ] start reading the
stars and [ __ ] yeah duh north star
come on now
they didn't know how to do that oh
really oh okay yeah they were really not
prepared for this
uh how did they go out there they said
they've done this trip before and they
were using the west coast of vela vela
island and gizel island or gizo yeah
island to their left as a guide and they
say we've done it before we should have
been fine but um once
uh the sea started to be choppy it got
rough
and a few hours into their journey they
they got into a storm there was heavy
rain strong winds you couldn't see the
cause like a [ __ ] and they're
like i don't know where i'm at if your
coastline is your guide you're [ __ ]
yeah yeah especially during a storm so
then they were like oh [ __ ] it got bad
it got worse
gps eventually died we couldn't see
where we're going so we just decided to
stop the engine and wait to save fuel
and all they did was survive off of
oranges that they packed for the trip
for scurvy it lasted a month for scurvy
nice hey nice wait is that no yeah
that's a big because the british ships
that's why they call them limey's
they're not black vitamin c yeah vitamin
c dude they've had limes and oranges
made that up
oranges i don't know anything about
anything
that's how i feel exactly
but no they and they had also coconuts
they collected from the sea
that had fallen in the sea and like like
um they swam out for that must be and
then um rainwater that they used uh a
piece of canvas to collect wow these
shows are beasts they didn't put any
they didn't fish huh
no fishing they did not fish there's
gonna be a movie about this soon yeah
there's piranhas in there bro they were
so weak by the time that they got found
damn um that they
had to be carried off the boat
by people oh my god because they were
just so friendly so how were they found
um they were
it was just a fishing boat that ended up
finding them they should have been
fatter there was this one fat guy that
did a 300-day fast
a water fast wow because he was so fat
i'm talking like dude was obese like 500
600 pounds no way some guy was so fat
that he could fast for 300 yeah that's
like almost a whole year definitely need
to be [ __ ] fat for like
ever like that's [ __ ] fat yeah maybe
like yeah six seven pounds 700 pounds
would you like 900 pounds i don't know
but he just did a water fast
and he he was able to survive
just on [ __ ] metabolizing it yeah
body will eat itself did he lose weight
at least lose the weight
he gained weight
for the water
drinking too much water too much water
that's [ __ ] okay i almost don't
believe you i kind of want him to google
it google it
just be like
uh
fat
obesity fat [ __ ] or like longest
longest fasting streak or something your
body will eat itself yo i get that but
damn for 300 days longest like water
faster literally the true story of a man
who survived without any food for
382 days oh over a year yeah holy [ __ ]
how [ __ ] sound i don't lie i know i
said i almost don't believe i just want
to see it
joe took that personally too he's a
savant
so most people can survive without food
for at least a few weeks maybe a bit
longer eventually starvation kills you
yet the limits on how long people can go
are complicated take the story of this
cat he's 32 days ending july 11th 1966.
he ate nothing
uh prior to that wow just the water fast
but how fat though how fat was he to
start though because like there's also
other things it's not just like eating
away your own fat there's like liver
failure there's like a bunch of things
if you don't get vitamins 450 pounds
380 days off of 450 pounds
doctors put them on a short fast like it
would help them lose weight although
they didn't expect them to keep it off
but as days without food turn into weeks
he felt eager to just continue he was in
the zone bro
the longest i've done was a 72 hour
and
i wasn't hungry
until the 48th or 40 like the second or
yeah and what was the reason i just
wanted to try it because i was starting
to study fasting and just how the body
works and um it was just one of the ways
of like i guess losing weight and then
people could say it's unhealthy whatever
whatever but naturally healthy now it's
like um humans
would miss a meal for like one whole day
it was normal and did you lose weight
oh yeah i lost weight and i think most
people will lose weight
but
i don't know it's still controversial
because you know you shouldn't not eat
and it's dangerous
but
just missing one day won't kill you well
scientists said they did regular blood
sugar tests and they discovered that he
was sneaking pastrami sandwiches
dude these blood tests are very advanced
they can tell you exactly what kind of
food the hat i sense that there's the
hat
what the philly cheesesteak they saw a
beef owl jew as well
you son of a [ __ ] steve he was sneaking
combo number five at the local burger
king
in my head i was like i [ __ ] knew it
pastrami sandwiches yeah
well i i intermittent fast so i don't i
don't like i mean like i give my body
weight
but i feel much better because um when
i'm eating all the damn time and i'm
always stuffed i actually feel gross
i feel good but gross like after four
days of it i started feeling sick in
hawaii did you eat like dude
15 pounds like it was pretty you know in
like a week two weeks no like in like
almost three months oh but that's
because i've been to hawaii like two
times
and then you living it up boy i lost
four pounds since i got back yeah yeah
same i gained 15 pounds during
quarantine i i think everybody well
that's not bad for a whole year yeah
it's about the average actually i think
it was about that yeah yeah i did less
than four months
yeah starting from going to mexico and
all this stuff before his first meal
after the fast he claimed to have
forgotten the taste of food for
breakfast on that july morning when he
had his first meal he ate a boiled egg
slice of bread with no butter
a cup of black coffee and a pastrami
sandwich
and he says he couldn't taste anything
like that
sandwich out here too i won't put him
over bro
that that uh [ __ ] egg coffee whatever
toasting that reminds me of recording
for a dream you gotta ease your um like
you gotta ease into eating when when you
fast yeah you can't come back in with
like gnome shrimp right away you know
nope that's actually probably the best
meal you could break a fast with long
chin or kinja bank noodles
kenji bangle will ease you in it's like
real nice and sweet like air dried never
fried no soup
plant-based but if you go know right
away you're gonna die it will literally
kill you so don't even eat namashim
anymore when i when i was uh
got out of boot camp so boot camp eat
like like almost like jail food right
like your cafeteria and it's very bland
very it's just literally for nutrients
then when your parents come for
graduation there's family day and i've
been eyeing the a w that's on base
like we would [ __ ] go up and down i
would see that alienware in the corner i
know during family they can go to like
the shopping center the souvenir so i've
been eyeing the [ __ ] a w
so like when it was family day i got a
burger root beer float [ __ ] like
chili cheese fries and then in the uh
souvenir part i got probably like 12
packs of reese's peanut butter cups i
pounded all that [ __ ] and then i had
diarrhea the [ __ ] whole night yeah
from like 12 all the way to like 6 a.m
that'll did you regret it
was it good it was good though it was
worth it yeah i was there when my
brother left boot camp and it was the
same [ __ ] he want to go to burger king
mcdonald's everything eat the most bland
food for [ __ ] like two three months
you'll make a list yo yeah don't make a
list like when i used to cut weight for
like competitions i would literally
while i'm cutting away for like three
months i'm just writing down making a
list of all the foods i'm gonna eat and
it was torture because as soon as you'd
finished you would [ __ ] consume all
that and then blow up like
like nothing bro you weren't you spent
all this time trying to get in shape and
then as soon as you finish you just
binge eat until like 15 pounds later
not very healthy
but it's fun though very fun
do you feel like dog [ __ ] why was all
the food bland is that intentional
um i think so it's just like mass
produced like
military it's not meant to make your
life happy
burgers and ruby floats is all
mass-produced too
yeah but i don't know it's not made to
like i don't get your dopamine and like
you know they want you to come back
that's why yeah that's what i'm saying
is it like intentionally bland for like
a certain like health performance yeah
yeah probably keep your blood pressure
low or not increase sodium that's true
because they can't pump you up with
sugar and salt yeah right or else you'll
get sick yeah bart you've seen dwayne
johnson's like cheat meal days oh my god
[ __ ]
do i do that yeah he does every morning
he's [ __ ] steak and eggs and pancakes
every day
no that's that's high protein carbs yeah
it's
oh sorry egg whites even though you got
giant pancakes with it you're dipping it
you don't even [ __ ] use a fork you're
like he [ __ ] man handles a whole
pancake and he dips in and [ __ ] roll
it yeah he rolls a pancake and i'm
always sitting here like why don't we
get pancake orders on our [ __ ] jk
spreadsheet because i'm buying myself
[ __ ] junebe matcha and [ __ ]
lemonade or whatever the [ __ ] whack
[ __ ] i hate that if i'm on a strict diet
then i'll have like a cheat meal and
then i'll be like it it'll be
that one day i'll go crazy what's your
crazy meal let's go
oh man it depends on where i go he has
to strategize yeah like if it's a whole
day
um
any type of breakfast place i love i
love breakfast so like french toast like
cinnamon
roll french toast type of [ __ ]
and then i have to go to mcdonald's my
go-to place and i always get double
quarter pounder with cheese with the mac
sauce with fish fillet with chicken
nuggets with the mcflurry and two apple
pies and all at one time well one time i
have to dude that's like an egg two
thousand twenty five hundred calories
yeah you have that one and then i have
to do
probably one of those combo dinners
where it's like you you post mates from
both popeyes and like a pizza place so
you can have both at the same time wow
pizza and wings and then my ice cream
how do you add mac sauce to a quarter
pounder you say add max just tell them
yeah oh wow
they'll do it it's delicious chicken
sandwich with mac sauce is bomb too it
makes chicken with mac sauce is bomb
really i'm gonna try that okay gotta try
that mm-hmm it's all bomb little tip for
my dancer friend
i swear i actually swear you don't
believe me okay cool
[Music]
you